you have a tattoo on your hand but it's
really super faint like yeah barely
and I wasn't even sure is it like a
tattoo or like a bug bite I could yeah
it's a fleck of dirt it it's just to
remind me to drink more water but I have
I'm stupid tattooed on my hand
permanently why is that it's on there
wrong the - it's an h2o
yeah cute weird I didn't go to school
educated idiot so what did you like how
did you find out what H to watch how to
write out h2o Josh told me yourself
doing so I know I drew I mixed the color
because I didn't want I've never wanted
like a tattoo so this is actually Liam's
can't even think of a not cuss word to
call him no fair
so he we were like together after the
Hunger Games and Josh was gonna come
meet up and then we were getting
everybody was getting tattoos so then I
was like I don't want to get a tattoo so
I got one the color of a scar I got it
on wrong and then Liam bailed and didn't
get a tattoo and Josh never got one
either
wait they said they're gonna get tattoos
you go friends then they don't do it
yeah that's ridiculous
Josh didn't say that he would have done
it but he would have if bear had done it
then we would have both done why do you
call him bear what do you call Liam bear
he's an animal family there they're real
animals all the Hemsworth sir and all
it's the craziest family I've ever been
around in my life the way that they
communicate it's so physical and crazy
like it'll be like I hate this scabbit
I'll give you five bucks
really
like was like they eat like that they're
disgusting they're real bears they're
animals yeah they're so it's like
because I come from a family and some of
us are big guys we don't eat scabs but
we I'm growing up
unless it's perfectly prepared it was
funny to bust in on his friend that was
in the shower and cut his hair off wait
there were 10 that's a crime alien but
like he's also just like Oh like he's
just he's just does he is it hard to eat
around him I bet he's like just tearing
it does he grab the meat off the middle
of the table and just tear at it he used
to now he's vegan he's a vegan bear
that's ridiculous that doesn't work I
know it doesn't
I don't must have tofurkey every time
we're at dinner I'm like oh you would
love this you'd love this I was like I
can't eat it wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]